brian windhorst from the worldwide
leader in sports joining us here on the
program how have you been brian
windhorst
hey rich i know not all of your audience
heard it but you making
references to seinfeld and i'm going to
get you suckers
so reassuring to me because i'm in my
40s now i'm what you know when i was a
kid and they said men of a certain age
i'm now a man of a certain age and i
i'd like to thank you for doing that
because
i feel like when i talk about seinfeld
that i lose some of my audience now they
don't know and it's and i'm i
i'm happy that you and i can connect on
them yes
yes indeed uh because the two of us
together were real and spectacular ryan
you know thank you sir so um let's get
right into it what is lebron talking
about
let's how about that as just a a grand
entrance on this because there was a lot
about lebron in cleveland and feeling
nostalgic and
wanting to play with his son whenever
ronnie is available to hit the nba and
we don't know if that's what the lakers
i mean i'll give you the floor on what
you think was on lebron james's mind
this weekend
yeah it was a tough couple of weeks to
be a laker because um
nothing at the trade deadline although
i'm going to be honest with you i don't
think that there was a deal there that
they could have made that would have
made a material difference but lebron
had come out and been clear
he expected slash wanted a move at the
deadline and they didn't make one
um then rob polinka and i mean i haven't
spoken to rob about this um
my guess is he didn't intend to do this
but
when he came out after the trade
deadline on deadline day he
basically alluded to but lebron was on
the same page as him without doing
anything and
as somebody who occasionally in the last
20 years has
incorrectly implied that lebron felt
something and felt the fiery wrath of
lebron's
disapproval of that position
lebron has made him pay for that ever
since and then anthony davis goes down
with uh with an injury to his foot that
is pretty much
the wrecking ball to the last vestiges
of this lakers season um
now you've got lebron in cleveland um
going on a
passive aggressive attack
uh firing at the front office firing at
uh ownership you know hinting about his
future
i really think
part of it is he's punishing them for
the
the inaction at the trade deadline and
part of it is him sending the message
i would not do that again this summer
you better make some changes but it
isn't the roster as it currently stands
something put together with the
uh input if not full
faith and credit of lebron james the
blue check mark if you will from at king
james with whatever the roster has put
together westbrook and carmelo isn't
that
isn't this lebron essentially putting it
together
yes rich and that's what i think most
rational people say
but what you have to understand is
lebron doesn't care yes he put it
together and now he wants taken apart
and he's done that before he put
the roster he was a large influence in
the way the roster was put together his
first year in la and that roster didn't
get it done and he helped rip at the
shreds and now he's prepared to do it
again
and i think the lakers are sitting there
calling but lebron we've
and all of this roster changeover we've
traded everything and spent all this
money and you know now you're talking
about trading picks you know
six years into the future five six years
into the future when you're going to be
long gone and lebron doesn't care i mean
that's just the reality of it uh when he
was in cleveland um
you know he you know at the end of his
tenure there four years in which is
where he is with the lakers now he
locked horns with dan gilbert dan
gilbert ended up trading seven
first-round picks while lebron was there
and at the end he was tired of trading
them and lebron ended up forcing him
into it because he's so good
and the chances of him giving you a
chance to win the title are so
you know
rare and so valuable that it usually
gets done and so basically what i like i
know that there are people who are
trying to extrapolate from everything
that he's doing and saying that he wants
to leave los angeles from what i
understand that's not the case
he just wants them to go and push all
the chips into the middle and that means
even if it takes all the draft picks
you've got left to trade even if it
takes ripping this team apart he wants
him to do it and so
they didn't do at the deadline so now he
is putting them on notice you better do
it this summer and if they don't do it
this summer
it's worth pointing out that he has one
year left on his contract but we're not
at that point yet i don't think this is
about that you mentioned his son
yes rich he absolutely would love the
idea you know
his
one of his father figures
um at nike is a man named lynn merritt
most ninety-nine percent of the
basketball world doesn't know who lynn
merritt is but lynn merritt
is a king maker at nike if you you know
he's the guy who
goes and finds the teenagers and says
you get a 50 million nike contractor you
get a 10 million nike contract or in the
case of lebron you get a 100 million
nike contract and this win has been
sitting at the side of lebron for the
last 20 years and
you know lynn is for example you'll
notice that over the last decade or so
lebron has become extremely interested
in the legacy of muhammad ali he's
made documentaries he's he's sort of
fashioned some of his off-court
you know wife around doing some of the
same stuff muhammad ali did lynn merritt
is from louisville grew up in the next
town over from muhammad ali and regards
muhammad ali as his icon what does that
have to do with lebron's son well lynn
merritt's other major major major star
that he shepherded through nike was ken
griffey jr
ken jr and lebron had a relationship
when he was first coming to nike
and lebron treasured the idea that ken
griffey jr
played with his father
uh and it's still an iconic thing in
baseball that they play with the same
team so i think it was one season with
the mariners if i'm not mistaken
so yes lebron loves the idea of playing
with brony and it's something he's
thought about for a long time and
something i'm sure that lynn has
described and even ken griffey himself
has described
to lebron
but bronnie is 17. he will not be
eligible for the nba for two more years
and i don't even know if he's going to
be ready in two years he's he's regarded
as a four-star prospect uh he will
definitely get the chance to do whatever
he wants for that one year in college i
don't know if he's gonna be ready for
the nba what lebron is doing right now
is not related to brawny he's got two
more seasons to play that's a lot of
basketball between now and that brian
windhorst here on the rich eisen show in
terms of what you just mentioned let's
parse it out
um
what you just mentioned about lebron's
summer plans and how the lakers he's
expecting maneuvers to be made
is it too cynical to ask how about that
for a wind-up is it too cynical to ask
which rich paul clients he's interested
in
for the lakers
no not necessarily okay so what is it
what is he thinking he's smart enough
and
savvy enough to be further down the road
um and looking at the chessboard
what are these what do these potential
maneuvers look like
well i i don't i don't want to say
something here that will then be used
against me later okay but but let me
just say that
in a in a vacuum is it a good idea for a
player and his agency to be given so
much influence and power
with a team
in a vacuum he would say no that there
is a separation of that for a reason
old-school people like for example when
he was in miami with pat riley
riley would have never allowed anything
like this okay
but
whatever you want to think about rich
paul and and and
and the lakers
without rich paul the lakers would not
have a championship
i mean
he should have been absolutely given one
of the
one of the real diamond rings you know
when teams give out their rings they
give out you know the real diamonds to
the players and then you know they say
oh we gave them to our
our uh you know our our support staff
our our scorers table you know our our
public relations folks
you know our ushers there's those people
aren't getting the same i rich deserved
a real diamond ring when the lakers won
and the reason is because
it was rich paul that brought kentavious
caldwell pope to the lakers it was rich
paul
that
basically you know forced anthony davis
to the lakers he was
whacking off
um knocking away um uh interest from all
these other teams going doing these
interviews
telling these other teams don't trade
for anthony davis he's only going to be
a laker he practically
flew the plane to get anthony davis from
the from the the pelicans to the lakers
without rich paul and lebron working in
concert
the lakers don't get that title okay no
and mike and my question just so it you
know i make sure
everyone knows as well is i'm not at all
broadsiding rich paul or clutch sports
or what you know it's clearly uh he's
got a uh
a group of talent that can win you a
championship and clearly lebron that's
why i said is this one of those
maneuvers where lebron will take anybody
but clearly you might have a preference
for a clutch sports rich paul client and
with does this give you an indication as
to who he thinks and what moves he
thinks can be made come july
to make his final year in los angeles if
not two
um
championship ones like that
i don't think it has to be a clutch
client i do think there has to be change
so then what what does he think then
what does he have in mind what do you
think well
here's what i think i think if there's
trades out there to trade the 2027 and
2029 first round picks
he doesn't care he wants to trade it
and you know um
genie bus she's the steward of the
franchise right
she's the person who has to say listen
we we got to be careful giving away
a draft pick six years from now when
lebron will be you know owning um you
know a baseball team or an nba team you
know we can't
you know
and it's lebron pushing back and saying
trade russell westbrook trade this guy
trade that guy trade the draft picks i
don't care do what the rams did
trade all the picks who cares that's
what lebron wants hmm
and i guess is there any one specific
player in mind that he thinks he can be
hooked up with
like who's the third person in like the
third person in was was his idea was
westbrook maybe a little bit of carmelo
um clearly that's not working out right
now and it doesn't appear like it will
ultimately this year
we don't know yet okay i mean i i could
say some names and then be blasted up on
aggregation sites
but yes do it
don't really yeah we don't really know
yet we just have to see what i can tell
you is
the lakers not doing anything at the
trade deadline
was not what he wanted to see you know i
told this story
in what i wrote yesterday was on espn
in 2018
midway through the year lebron was
really frustrated with the cavs they had
traded uh kyrie irving when he demanded
a trade the year before and they just
weren't very good
and
he basically took his foot off the gas
and he went from playing like an mvp
level player to just sort of being an
all-star player and the cavs started
taking losses
and you know the front office was kind
of pacing back and forth like what are
we supposed to do here he's a free agent
he won't extend his contract with us how
do we trade more stuff we don't even
think he's going to be here
and lebron was just playing worse and
worse so finally the trade deadline the
night before the deadline they agreed to
they were going to do
three deals that were going to bring
four role players
rich
i could let you guess for the next 10
minutes i'll bet you couldn't even
remember who they traded for okay right
but that night they told lebron before
the game hey we're going to trade all
these guys
and lebron went out and had 37 15 and 10
hit a buzzer beater was completely
engaged and was so happy
and the executives realized the the cavs
executives were looking at each other
and they realized
we just traded for lebron
i mean yeah we're getting four role
players we're swapping out some guys
we'll get a little bit better we just
traded for a more engaged lebron
and so what the lakers i think are going
to have to come to terms with is
this summer
they may have to trade
for lebron
uh to to make sure that he remains
engaged especially because
if they don't you know he has one year
left on his contract he's allowed to
extend this off season in august is the
date when he's allowed to start
extending they have to start thinking
about making sure that he's fully
invested
he got reinvested in 2018 had a great
postseason run one of the great
postseason runs of his career
and left in free agency and the cavs got
a trip to the finals out of it and so
that's the deal you make
uh and that's and if you if you've done
your research and i assume the lakers
did and if they didn't
i can't help them
you should have known when you sign up
to play with lebron this is what you
sign up for you sign up to completely
exhaust your entire
franchise to try to make him win for the
time that he is there brian windhorst
here in the rich eisen show few minutes
left with you and uh i want to spend
that on ben simmons
when do we see him play
in brooklyn before the nets
my colleague ramona shelburne who has
done terrific reporting with inside
information on ben simmons for months
said yesterday it's a matter of weeks
not months and my i like staggered when
she said that
um because i'm go
saturday night i'm going to the bucs
nets game it's our abc game on saturday
night and i was thinking
maybe ben would be back for that game
i guess not um
and you know ramona didn't just say that
flippantly she knows
and so
my thing is i am going to circle march
10th
march 10th is when the nets play their
final scheduled game of the season
at the sixers
and as far as i know ben is not injured
um you know he's been dealing with some
mental health uh challenges and so that
is not something you put a schedule on
so i don't know uh to me it's
fascinating about whether he plays
before march 10th or not
so
it would be
see that's that's the conundrum with
this whole conversation brian i'll just
walk through the front door with you is
this the conversation is was it was
mental health uh the issue before
you know the shots
weren't taken in the playoffs were they
uh and you know made worse by the
reaction to what happened in
philadelphia is it something that uh
caused him to not go to the olympics and
work on his game like you suggested on
this very program um
[Music]
was it the cause of of of him
not uh showing up to philadelphia ready
to play or was this all something that
was put out there
to make everybody back off ben simmons
desire to not play for philadelphia and
and now we're wondering what's going on
with the nets and
i don't know what to make of it and i
know it's it's a very touchy subject and
very unfair potentially to simmons
or to anyone else who does have mental
problems you know like i don't know what
to make of it
the reason that is is causing an issue
with credibility
is because of the way that it came out
um
if
it had if ben had identified that
as a reason why he was not joining the
sixers from the start of the season
then i think it would have been
understood a little bit better
the issue came when
he reported to the 76ers
and after holding out trying to get
traded throughout training camp
and he started getting fine started
racking up and then he reported
and then it came out that that's what it
was
had that been handled in a different
order i think it would have been
perceived differently and so
of course you have to respect
what he's going through i i can't relate
to it so i have to yield but
you know in terms of the
i know that it sounds very coarse
to talk about the public relations
of announcing an issue with mental
challenge with mental health challenges
but the public relations of it made this
more difficult from a pr standpoint
but we will see harden this week correct
this is when we're going to see him
first up
right i believe so but i have to say
we're in a new nba that i'm
still grappling with where harden
announces that his hamstring is fine but
that he's not going to play for a while
including in the all-star
so i don't you know the credibility
of him and his injuries and speaking
about his injuries to me is shot
so
i guess is my answer
and so um
championship or busts
in philadelphia for hardin right this
year or or however long he stays
is that a fair that's why i thought they
had to make the trade he's i believe
he's 33.
joel embiid is absolutely awesome he is
just killing the league and
you know if you watch the all-star game
you know in the fourth quarter of the
all-star game
is now one of the most competitive
things that you see it's one of the
strangest things the first three
quarters are an absolute joke but now
the fourth quarter with the way they've
made it like it's a referendum
on a who's who of the nba to me
the greatest compliment you can kind of
give a player in the regular season is
that he's out there on the court in the
fourth quarter of the all-star game and
you know it was kind of fascinating to
go back and see
who they wanted on the court and who
wasn't on the court okay
two years ago when they first did this
joel embiid was the best player on the
court
in that game in chicago his team ended
up not winning he was the best player on
the court
on on on sunday night
you see who was making the plays in the
fourth quarter it was embiid who's
probably going to win the mvp it was
giannis the two-time mvp and the
reigning champ it was lebron
it was like
this is this is when the the big boys
you know make their statements
and b was awesome in that game and so
this is indeed's time and so to import a
player like harden the sixers had to do
it now they had to do it now because you
don't know how long james harden is
going to be at this level you don't know
when joelle embiid is going to be at
this you know healthy at this level
even if you waited until the summer you
would have missed a chance at biting the
apple this time
so
the sixers to my mind are let's watch
them they're almost the most compelling
story in the nba after the break
right before the break the last game
thursday night they go into milwaukee
milwaukee's got all their star players
silly wins in milwaukee without hardin
coming back b puts up 42.
philly to me is the most compelling
thing we got going and especially when
harden comes here pretty soon
all right brian i love talking to you
man um and i really appreciate the
extended amount of time that you just
gave me i just need 90 seconds more what
do you make of cj mccollum saying he
hasn't spoken his eye on yet
jaw-dropping
jaw-dropping
and um i you know i know j.j redick my
colleague at espn who by the way is no
fan of the pelicans after the way he was
treated he has no incentive
to
sugarcoat anything on the pelicans went
in on his former teammate zion today um
you should check that out um
[Music]
just jaw jaw-dropping and um you know
the thing about it is is that those of
us in the media we don't know zion i've
never had a chance to meet him because
he is very very kept very very insulated
and he has existed in the nba mostly in
pandemic time or injured so
we don't have
reliable reporting
on how zion is actually doing there's a
ton of stuff out there with
you know
dubious sourcing and so i don't know
what to believe but there's nobody
speaking on zion's behalf and the team
quite frankly seems petrified of saying
anything so the fact that cj mccollum
who's a 30 million dollar player who the
team just brought in as sion's running
mate hadn't even spoken him even on text
was just jaw-dropping and it also says a
lot i know that the team's public
relations or ticket sales staff doesn't
determine things but certain things are
clear the pelicans sent out their um
their season ticket package uh uh
promotional material uh over the weekend
and it didn't have zion's name even
in it
uh because they can't sell him right now
they can't with a straight face sell him
um i am i've he has jaw-dropping talent
i think the world of his ability but i
just think it's fascinating the way
decisions are being made around him and
not in a good way
brian you're the man thanks for the time
look for my call uh i love our chats you
make me smarter and i it's just always
always terrific thanks for the call be
well rich take care you bet that's brian
windhorst i follow him on twitter you
should as well just a dynamite reporter
dynamite yeah man hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here